how many hours would you say on the
property business you're working right
now a week an hour a day an hour a day
on the whole property business yeah I
think so I normally get home about over
six o' so your most your work then is on
your plumbing business yeah so that's
where majority of the work is but you
don't want to quit that just yet because
you're still making decent money do it
do you make more money on the property
business or on the plumbing business
right now last month is probably
property business hold on a minute hang
on a minute bro so you're working an
hour day on the property business sounds
but the property business is making more
than the plumbing business how many
hours are you working on the plumbing
business way too many 60 hours a week
what how do you make sense of that it's
a first time I thought about that